so greg when you think about raw egg
consumption what comes to mind
man so two things come to mind uh the
first thing that comes to mind obviously
is rocky one um second thing that comes
to mind is when i started getting into
lifting my parents initially were just
like very
just completely against the use of
protein powder or supplements in any
form so kind of kind of v1 of this
before the raw eggs come in
is
instead of letting me drink protein
shakes just like buy some powder mix it
up whatever um they would only let me
well not let me buy they would buy these
for me i think to to make sure i wasn't
like buying protein behind their back
but they would buy me ensure drinks yeah
like the the stuff for
for like people who can't chew or digest
food well um
man those are
[ __ ] rough they have the
they have the consistency
of sweetened condensed milk like they're
unbelievably viscous and they also don't
have that much protein i think it was
like 15
uh grams per can or something like that
they're like a protein supplement for
someone with
no athletic related uh
goals right right just like getting
enough protein to be a healthy adult
correct yeah uh
and so yeah like
trying to chug two of those after a
workout
was just miserable yeah um so eventually
they relented a little bit and said okay
like you like you can get a basic
protein supplement but initially they
limited me i think to just one scoop a
day and they certainly wouldn't let me
touch mass gainers um but you know i was
at this point just getting into
powerlifting i think i was like maybe
160 170. um and i i've mentioned this on
the podcast before like my
my first training crew were
all guys who were
very strong
uh untested multiplied multiply lifters
who had some
in hindsight
unhelpful ideas about how much people
should weigh at particular heights so
you know for them
it's like oh you're you're like 5 10.
you
need to at least be a 242 probably a
275.
that
probably wasn't a great idea to get
lodged in my brain that young but it did
uh and so i was like dude like i i need
to gain weight and i'm training all the
time still playing sports very active um
so if you can believe it at one point in
my life i did actually have some
struggle with putting on weight just
because my activity level was so high um
and since i couldn't use mass gainers i
had to come up with my own
that in hindsight was was far worse and
just like more inherently dangerous than
just buying a mass gainer would be um
but every morning i would mix myself up
a mass gain or shake where
most of the protein just had to come
from raw eggs because like i couldn't
use that much protein powder so it would
be
whole milk ice cream
peanut butter
uh like a scoop or two of protein powder
and then like a dozen raw eggs and i
just throw it in the blender mix it up a
dozen
maybe it was like eight it was at least
six it was a it was a good number of raw
eggs which i'll note like so eggs kind
of like have a weird smell and taste
mostly from like the the sulfurous
compounds in the yolk but
those don't go volatile and really like
affect the the smell or taste that much
until they're cooked so drinking raw
eggs is not as unpleasant as one would
assume especially if you got some some
ice cream and peanut butter in the mix
but anyway i i'd make i'd mix that shake
up pour it into a half gallon bottle and
just drink on it from the morning until
about 4 p.m that day that's disgusting
um which is again like that
so in terms of food safety very bad idea
in terms of like the bacteria i was
ingesting probably very gross on a on a
purely hedonic just like gustatory basis
it was fine like it tasted okay and the
taste didn't get
meaningfully worse throughout the day uh
but anyway in hindsight it is very funny
that they were totally fine with me
consuming like a dozen room temperature
raw eggs every day
but wouldn't let me use a mass gainer um
but anyway so that's that's the first
thing that comes to mind when i think
raw eggs just i i used to consume a lot
of them yeah in a very dangerous way
yeah and you you mentioned uh the rocky
balboa movie franchise and you know
that's why they were fine with me
drinking the raw eggs like my my father
loves the rocky movie franchise and he's
like
look man like sly stallone wouldn't lead
people astray if he's willing to put
himself on the silver screen drinking
raw eggs they've got to be safe for my
boy yeah i think that was kind of the
thought process well not just safe but
also
effective and hardcore correct right so
like when when someone says like hey you
know i'm taking my lifting really
seriously i'm going to have an omelette
for breakfast you just say well
an omelette is just a lovely breakfast
that's not very hardcore yeah but if you
say i'm going to crack four eggs into a
glass with nothing else and chug it
people are like oh [ __ ] you really want
to get big yeah you know and a lot of
that comes from
the kind of
implied connotations from how raw eggs
were featured within the rocky franchise
and i think specifically rocky one
so with that in mind
do you suspect raw egg consumption to be
better or worse or equivalent when it
when compared to cooked eggs
specifically in terms of like muscle
protein synthesis and building muscle
yeah so so now now that i'm a little
older and know no more things um i would
assume that raw eggs are probably worse
than cooked eggs um just because like
most
most
i think proteins in general certainly
animal proteins as far as i'm aware have
higher oral bioavailability after
cooking just because like the cooking
process
kind of unravels some of those proteins
makes them a little bit easier to digest
and i i believe that's particularly true
of egg protein so i would anticipate
that cooked is is better than raw
so i am going to in this segment cover a
new study that actually directly
compared raw versus cooked
egg consumption specifically looking at
acute muscle protein synthesis after
a resistance training stimulus so very
straightforward study but before we get
into that i want to take a little detour
and talk about protein quality it's
something i've talked about previously
on the show but not since we had all
these additional capabilities with
adding visuals and graphics and things
like that so i wanted to give a nice
little concise overview of protein
quality why it matters and then circle
back and talk about that study so first
of all uh protein quality is you know
there are several different scales that
are typically used to quantify it and
academics like to argue over which
scales were best and of course it
changes over time as people win
arguments and create new scales and then
have more arguments and win those
arguments so
if you look back at older research
you'll you'll see and current research
depending on the application people
talking about protein efficiency ratio
uh biological value net protein
utilization protein digestibility
corrected amino acid score i mean
there's a long list of these different
metrics that people use to basically say
not just which proteins better than
another but give me a number so that i
can really start ranking you know large
lists of different proteins and the
general idea behind protein quality is
like to what extent can a human being
consume this and really efficiently and
effectively utilize the proteins within
the food for building new human proteins
and when we're talking about fitness
stuff we're almost always talking about
building new muscle proteins right
that's really what people are are
interested in yeah so
you might be wondering why this matters
uh you know an egg is an egg so you'd be
thinking well these both have the same
protein quality uh but actually as you
alluded to raw versus cooked eggs you
know they have the same amino acid
breakdown or profile
that's one huge component that goes into
protein quality is what amino acids are
in this and in what relative magnitudes
but it's not just the amino acid profile
it's also the digestibility and like you
mentioned many proteins their
digestibility is influenced by the way
that they're processed or cooked
and eggs are no exception there was a
study by ivana poole and colleagues back
in 1998
and i'm going to put a little table on
the screen here
but
what we're looking at is the true ileal
digestibility
and what's really fascinating is you
might think okay cooking a protein maybe
it takes it from like 85 digestibility
up to like 92 right in the case of of
this study they found that that
percentage of true ileal digestibility
went up from 51 to 91
by cooking it so we're talking about a
very considerable difference in uh this
particular metric of protein
digestibility
so with this in mind uh
someone might very justifiably assume a
cooked egg same amino acid profile but
way better digestibility surely this is
going to promote muscle protein
synthesis to a greater extent than raw
eggs
and then again very justifiably they
would say well if it builds muscle
better over five hours you know
literally building new muscle proteins
surely that means it's going to build
more muscle over five weeks or five
years right so we we have this tendency
to say well if it's better for muscle
protein synthesis in the short term
surely it's better for hypertrophy in
the long term
so that brings me to this new study
head-to-head raw versus cooked eggs and
this was by do you know how to pronounce
that last name
i don't f-u-c-h-s i have no idea um
it's probably a german last name if i
had to guess the origin
yeah i i don't know i'm googling it real
quick yeah so anyway uh this study which
actually referenced rocky balboa in the
title
um all right are are are you ready i've
got it i've got it pulled up on youtube
okay
i'm gonna crank the volume
fuchs
pukes
fuchs all right
there we go
hopefully we don't get like a copyright
claim for for throwing that audio in i i
apologize
voxifier.com we we didn't mean to steal
your intellectual property uh so fuchs
yeah that that makes sense and it always
makes sense in hindsight when you look
up how to pronounce something but you're
like yeah that was one of the 35 ways i
would have tried yeah so anyway fuchs
and colleagues uh like like i was
mentioning they they specifically
mentioned uh rocky balboa in the title
which i thought was kind of clever um
but very straightforward study after a
resistance training session you know
they were they gave these protein uh
uh
treatments right so one group of people
got
uh cooked egg the other group got raw
egg and then a third group was like a
control group and if memory serves i
think they got a lovely croissant with
butter and a little bit of orange juice
nice so it was it was a much lower
amount of protein it was like five grams
of protein the other treatments uh going
based on memory i think they ended up
getting like i think it was five eggs
each and so that puts you in like the
20 to 30-ish range for for protein yeah
yeah it was a pretty standard protein
dose for someone who's trying to get a
really nice robust protein synthesis
response um so what they were looking at
here is
looking at uh plasma amino acid
responses so just after ingestion
how did key
amino acid levels change over the course
of the next few hours so when we talk
about key amino acids uh there's a few
we want to mention so leucine is a very
special amino acid in the sense that it
plays
a role in actually stimulating the
response of muscle protein synthesis it
plays more of like a signaling role of
telling the muscle hey
plenty of leucine here let's go ahead
and start building muscle right
and so the leucine is really important
for triggering that response and then
the essential amino acids are critical
because we need all of them to be there
and present in sufficient amounts so
that we can build new muscle proteins so
when you look at these amino acid
responses it's very common to say okay
what does the leucine look like are we
getting a big increase a really rapid
peak
and a sustained high level of leucine
and then same thing goes with with
essential amino acids are we getting a
really nice robust response with a
really big increase in blood levels
now i'm going to show on the screen here
the amino acid responses were very in
line with what you would expect right so
looking at blood levels of leucine
there was not a large increase at all
looking at the control group with had
which had that really low protein uh
meal
the uh the raw egg group did have a
noticeable increase
it looks like plasma leucine went down
in the control group if i if i'm looking
at the right figure yeah i i should have
put the actual time amount on the uh the
x-axis there i i think that just has to
do with the preceding resistance
training stimulus oh gotcha that impacts
those acute dynamics um but uh but yeah
the raw egg there was a noticeable
increase a significant increase
statistically speaking but the uh the
cooked
uh egg had a significantly greater
increase in blood leucine than the raw
egg so that would go in line with the
the assumption right you cook it the
digestibility goes up we have a better
more robust leucine response compared to
raw eggs
now if we look at total essential amino
acids in the blood it was the same exact
pattern so the control group it actually
dropped off a little bit and there was a
little reduction
the raw egg did have an increase but the
cooked eggs had an even greater increase
so
based on the blood amino acid levels you
would say this is going exactly as how i
would expect and surely we're going to
have a better protein synthesis response
in the cooked egg group because of that
better amino acid response in the blood
yeah so so far this is exactly what i
predicted so let's let's just wrap this
segment up and
yeah that would be nice uh unfortunately
there's a complicating factor here
you're gonna see on the screen here
we're looking now at muscle protein
synthesis rates and what they did was
they looked at kind of baseline and then
they looked at the first two hours after
ingestion and then from hours two to
five and in the first two hours all
three groups had a significant increase
um but then when you look at
uh hours two to five you start to see
uh a bit of of a divergence there right
so when you look at hours two to five
you see that clearly
uh you know
statistical comparisons aside we see a
more robust increase in muscle protein
synthesis when we're looking at the raw
and the boiled eggs compared to the
control group
but when we when we start to compare the
raw and the boiled eggs they look
extremely similar i i mean they are
virtually identical when you're looking
at protein synthesis rates whether
you're looking at baseline zero to two
hours or two to five hours uh and then
once again they also included a figure
there where they were looking at uh just
overall that whole zero to five hour
time period after ingestion again
baseline all groups are pretty similar
looking at that entire five hour period
uh all groups did have an increase in
protein synthesis rates
and but when you look at the actual
magnitude of the increase once again the
raw eggs and the boiled eggs were very
very similar and in fact looking at that
zero to five hour when it's all
collapsed together the raw egg bar is
slightly higher not meaningful
whatsoever from a physiological
perspective but
whatever advantage we would expect from
the boiled eggs having a better
you know
immediate response in terms of amino
acid levels it simply did not translate
to muscle protein synthesis so there was
a favorable effect if you just look at
the the blood amino acid kinetics and
responses but for muscle protein
synthesis there was really no influence
of cooking when compared to the raw eggs
so this comes to a broader point about
protein there is
a chain of assumptions that a lot of
people make and the assumptions build on
each other right and so the chain goes
like this we look at these individual
protein sources one by one you'll you'll
often see people saying should i have
whey or casein or milk or egg or chicken
or beef whatever
a lot of times we'll look at these
things in a vacuum and say well first
i'm going to look at quality which is
based on amino acid composition and
digestibility and i'm going to assume
that better quality or higher quality
score leads to a better amino acid
response in the blood
and that necessarily leads to a better
muscle protein synthesis response
acutely and that necessarily leads to a
better hypertrophy response over time
helps me build more muscle over time and
a lot of times without explicitly
stating it a lot of people do assume
have a tendency to assume
that those relationships are like
perfectly correlated and also related in
magnitude in a very direct way so
a lot of times people assume if i have a
five percent better uh you know protein
quality score i'm gonna have a five
percent better response in blood amino
acid levels and a five percent better
muscle protein synthesis response and a
five percent better increase in muscle
over time
and what's really important to to
recognize is
if that kind of chain of assumptions
held true there would be things we would
expect to see in the literature that we
should be able to expect pretty reliably
you know so we should expect that the
studies looking at acute muscle protein
synthesis responses with all these
different acute feeding protocols of
this protein versus that protein they
should give us a very clear
reliable and predictable pattern of
which protein sources lead to more
protein synthesis
there should also be pretty clear
relationships by which
animal-based protein sources
very obviously and routinely outperform
plant-based protein sources whether
we're looking at protein synthesis or
long-term changes in muscle over time
yeah
we should see as an extension of that
that vegan and vegetarian diets
do very very poorly in studies compared
to omnivorous diets when we look at
these outcomes of protein synthesis and
hypertrophy over time and really even
among omnivorous diets if this chain of
assumptions held true with the type of
high correlation that some people expect
you know we should even expect that
people who eat a higher percentage of
animal-based proteins on an omnivorous
diet should have even better results
than someone who says you know maybe i'm
going to go kind of plant-based and only
get like 20 percent of my protein from
animal-based proteins right so
even within an omnivorous diet we should
see that
a general preference toward more higher
quality animal-based protein should
win out in the long run
and
one thing that's important i talked a
little bit about animal versus
plant-based protein sources the reason
that i group them and kind of categorize
them is lower versus higher quality
that's not a hard rule there are
low-quality animal-based proteins um
so like collagen
it's amino acid profile if you're trying
to build muscle is just rubbish it's
terrible and and the studies bear that
out it is not a good muscle building
supplement when we look at
soy that's a very high quality
plant-based protein but overall
plant-based protein sources tend to have
lower quality scores what i'm going to
show you is a series of figures from a
study by vanvlier and colleagues
and
what we see it's a bunch of different
protein sources plant and animal based
and human that's just to give a
representative example that is not
implying you should be eating human
muscle i would discourage that in the
strongest terms possible yeah i mean it
because it has considerably less leucine
than whey so exactly
yet another reason to not eat humans
like there's literally multiple reasons
yeah like at least two yeah
so uh but when you look at these
plant-based proteins generally speaking
they have lower leucine per gram of
protein
generally speaking they also have lower
essential amino acid levels uh per you
know per gram of protein although i i do
think it's worth pointing out that there
is considerable variability among
animal-based protein sources right so i
i find it a little bit ironic that
people say like oh i don't eat
plant-based proteins or i don't rely on
them because they're such low quality
but you never see those people splitting
hairs between like
whey and egg or or you know whey and
beef right they just consider it all to
be high quality protein but there is
still considerable vari variation there
you know i see on these lists that for
leucine content and amino acid content
cod is particularly low down
low down on the list as far as animal
proteins go which might make you feel a
little bit silly about trying to replace
me with dwayne the rock johnson is he a
baby
if memory serves he's he's a huge cod
head wow which that might make you
question some of his choices yeah yeah
i'll have to think about that i'm still
waiting for him to get back to me which
is strange because i sent that email
three years ago but we'll see
uh now i'm also going to show a figure
here of lysine and methionine
and the reason that this is important is
because
a lot of what we would call a low
what we would call low quality proteins
one of the main factors kind of uh
dictating you know if we're going to
just split into a dichotomy high versus
low quality like we can give them a
graded score and all that stuff but one
of the issues with a low quality protein
is generally speaking you know per the
definition it's going to be lacking at
least
one essential amino acid
uh so
you know
of all the essential amino acids there's
going to be at least one where it's
really falling short in a way that
inhibits its ability to support muscle
building to a maximal extent
and the the two most common ones that we
have to keep an eye out for are lysine
and methionine and we're going to come
back to that a little bit when i talk
about practical applications of
plant-based proteins um but but we can
definitely see that for a lot of uh
plant-based proteins you know they fall
a little bit short with either lysine or
methionine whereas animal-based proteins
tend to have plenty of both so so that's
a key distinction between them but when
we look at digestibility when we look at
essential amino acids leucine in
aggregate
animal-based proteins tend to
have better looking metrics than
plant-based proteins
and so
like i said with that kind of chain of
assumptions you would assume well surely
plant-based proteins are going to fall
way short when we look at the literature
for protein synthesis and hypertrophy
but that's really not the case um so
there are a couple meta analyses in the
last couple of years one by morgan and
colleagues one by lim and colleagues and
generally speaking they found that
you know that one of them was looking at
specifically plant versus animal based
the other was looking at high versus
lower quality proteins so like for
example i think there were some studies
in there that used collagen as the low
quality protein even though it's animal
based yeah uh but generally speaking you
know when you look at it uh acute muscle
protein synthesis the data generally
lean in favor of being of looking better
for these higher quality protein sources
and these animal-based protein sources
uh but there is a there there's some
mixed evidence there um i covered it in
a mass article uh a year or two back
where there's actually a surprising
amount of contradictions in some of
those head-to-head comparisons um but
nonetheless overall broadly speaking
generally the research indicates that
muscle protein synthesis acutely is
better for these higher quality proteins
especially when there's no resistance
training involved and that's important
because resistance training itself
provides a very robust stimulus for
muscle protein synthesis leucine and
amino acids aside yeah i mean even going
back to the to the study that uh like
the the main one about eggs that we're
talking about here
i mean it looks like just the resistance
training stimulus itself
increased muscle protein synthesis like
threefold over baseline
and
resistance training plus either version
of egg consumption
maybe increased muscle protein synthesis
four-fold over baseline so like the the
impact of training itself was
considerably larger than
protein oh absolutely yeah training and
having a lovely croissant with some
butter and orange juice
those people were in a good spot in in
terms of protein synthesis there you
know the the the extra protein from egg
just elevated it a little bit beyond
that
um
so generally speaking you know like i
said better acute muscle protein
synthesis findings for these higher
quality proteins but
when you introduce a resistance training
stimulus
uh that starts to muddy the waters a
little bit and then when you make the
leap and you stop looking at protein
synthesis and you instead look at things
like hypertrophy or strength development
over time
those differences really fade away
and i'm not going to get into all the
nuance and detail of why that's the case
but i am going to refer interested
individuals to a paper by watard and
colleagues called making sense of muscle
protein synthesis a focus on muscle
growth during resistance training the
entire uh premise of that paper or at
least the way i read it was to explore
why
in that chain of assumptions
things do break down along the way and
why we cannot look at a protein and make
a perfect assumption of how it's going
to impact muscle protein synthesis and
even if we could
protein synthesis
those acute studies really do not
predict long-term hypertrophy
nearly as well as we would hope that
they do so a lot of people will say you
need to eat this protein source because
it does way better in these acute
studies on protein synthesis
and those findings generally speaking do
not pan out particularly well for
long-term hypertrophy within certain
contexts you know that that reminds me a
lot of
like emg research like you go back five
six years there were a lot of
like a lot of well-meaning and generally
well-informed people um who
in like you know not throwing shade i
was one of them who would make like
pretty strong recommendations about like
oh you should do this exercise instead
of this other this other exercise to
grow this muscle group because look like
we see higher emg responses with
exercise a versus exercise b um
and you know like over time we've
learned more like yeah that's not really
a validated assumption and there are a
lot of situations where that assumption
like higher emg leads to
more effective training stimulus more
muscle growth where that assumption
breaks down um
and now i think a lot of people are
pretty wise to that but i don't think
that same level of
i guess skepticism is an okay word for
it has really reached uh protein
synthesis or protein quality data quite
yet yeah and to be fair i mean a lot of
this research is really developing
before our eyes you know a lot of the
research i'm talking about here the
meta-analyses the two studies i'm about
to mention these are all from the last
two years or so right so
two studies that really put this to the
test and i think we're really
eye-opening studies for a lot of folks
who
had a tendency to really micromanage the
minutia pertaining to their protein
sources one was by montane and
colleagues and what they did was they
looked at uh
a two two diets one was vegan the other
was omnivorous both provided 1.8 grams
of protein per kilogram of body mass per
day which would be within what we
consider kind of the optimal kind of
general range
and what they looked at was muscle
protein synthesis levels not acutely
after a single meal but longer term over
three days with resistance training
included in that protocol and what they
found was if you're eating plenty of
protein and these diets were
supplemented with a pretty decent amount
of mycoprotein which is a pretty high
quality plant well
it's a
fungi fungi based protein
uh they used to say it was mushroom
based but then they got hit
they ran into some litigation because
people were like this clearly is not a
mushroom and they're like right but no
one wants to eat fungus
but yeah mycoprotein is a fungus-based
uh
protein source that uh that fits within
vegan diets and and has a pretty solid
uh set of characteristics for protein
quality
but uh generally speaking
1.8 grams per kilogram per day over this
three-day period uh both groups whether
it was vegan or omnivorous had similar
uh protein muscle protein synthesis
rates over those three days so that
gives us more information than looking
at a single meal but still it's protein
synthesis it's not hypertrophy but that
was covered shortly thereafter in a
study by javier lorraine and colleagues
they were looking at 1.6 grams per
kilogram per day
in a diet that did have a significant
amount of soy protein uh rather than
mycoprotein
soy again a really nice plant-based
protein with some really
favorable characteristics so i'm not
indicating that protein quality is fully
irrelevant and that's an important thing
these diets had some myco proteins some
soy some other kind of conventional food
products that have that have plant-based
protein so i'm not saying plant uh you
know protein quality is irrelevant you
know just have collagen and you'll be
fine that that is of course an
indefensible statement
what what my general argument is getting
toward is
we want to just have a mixture of pretty
okay proteins and that seems to be just
as good as micromanaging and saying well
what if i increase the protein score
from 87 to 92 right the effect of that
is is zero right so i'll get to those
practical applications as we go but
since i highlighted mycoprotein and soy
as being pretty high quality proteins it
is relevant to mention uh but but we'll
we'll put all those pieces together in a
moment but in this case again eating
enough protein 1.6 not a super high
amount right so back in the day a lot of
folks would say well you can do fine on
a vegan diet but you have to eat
way way way more protein than an
omnivore
this study directly contradicted that
and found that over a very you know kind
of standard resistance training study
timeline longitudinal study in
conjunction with resistance training
whether you were on a vegan diet or an
omnivorous diet both groups had very
similar improvements in strength and
hypertrophy so
like i was saying my main premise here
is not that protein quality is
irrelevant that's an indefensible
statement but it's that we need to
change the way we view that kind of
chain of assumptions and i think we need
to work backwards so the goal here is to
support maximal or near maximal
hypertrophy responses to training right
and if we work back it's not that we
need to start with protein quality score
and build up from there but we need to
work backwards and say in order to get
this great hypertrophy sp response
i need to find proteins that give me a
good enough
muscle protein synthesis response so it
doesn't have to be the best one when we
compare head to head i need my muscle
protein synthesis response to this
protein to simply be good enough yeah
and how do i get there i need to make
sure that i have a blood amino acid
response that isn't way better than all
the other comparators it just has to be
good enough to get me there yeah and how
do i get that good blood amino acid
response
i just need the amino acid composition
and the digestibility of that protein
source once again
to simply be good enough
uh so these little mine you know tiny
minute differences comparing one to the
other they don't seem to be that
informative what we need to do is make
sure that at each channel each step of
this chain along the way we need to have
protein sources that are simply good
enough to get the job done which lends
itself to the question
how good is good enough like how do we
go about sorting through different uh
protein sources within kind of a
conventional diet
not looking into like hyper-specialized
protein sources or anything like that
and you know it's frankly extremely easy
to find protein sources that are
more than sufficient to support
hypertrophy to essentially to a near
maximal level so uh what we're trying to
do here is over the course of a full day
make sure you don't have any glaring
shortcomings when it comes to essential
amino acid coverage so like i said some
proteins are going to be short on lysine
or methionine you want to make sure you
don't have any massive oversights there
you also want to make sure that you are
selecting and preparing food sources in
a manner that simply
conforms to basic preparation guidelines
you want to cook things the way they're
supposed to be cooked but but generally
speaking if like when we're talking
about these studies with like uh the soy
the soy study the mico protein study
i didn't see anything in the methods i
could have missed it i didn't see
anything where they were saying oh by
the way we also were extremely
meticulous about arranging the other
protein sources in the diet it was just
like hey
you're on a vegan diet let me guess
you're going to be eating wheat and rice
and corn and beans and whatever right
like the other protein is just coming in
from just eating foods that that find
their way into kind of standard typical
diets
um now that leads me to a question greg
so so the overall goal here like i said
no massive shortcomings for essential
amino acids uh and just eating stuff in
a preparation method that is advisable
and making sure that you're not having
any stomach discomfort due to poor
digestibility
a lot of
omnivores
to
you know
go in line with that original chain of
assumptions and say oh crap
i need to make sure that i have all of
the highest quality protein source
except a lot of people don't realize
like they'll make like protein oats and
be like well i put in 24 grams of whey
protein so this meal had 24 grams of
protein it's not the case oats have
protein and usually more than people
think yeah so usually omnivores who are
into into lifting will make that
realization it's like oh my god
a considerable portion of my diet is
crappy protein i mean i've seen people
even put forth the idea that like you
know the the 1.6 to 2.2 grams of protein
per kilogram per day or whatever that's
uh that's specifically just for high
quality animal protein yeah like like
you should be aiming to get that much
animal protein in per day not just total
which
that
is directly counter to the research well
i was gonna say i don't wanna be an
[ __ ] but like
that that range of numbers comes from a
study yeah you can just look at the
study and say is that what these numbers
mean correct yeah and they don't yeah
but anyway yeah back to being nice and
charitable so
some people will say like crap i need to
really tighten this up and stop counting
all my lower quality plant-based
proteins and only count my high-quality
ones from animal sources
so greg
what percent of daily protein
in an omnivorous diet comes from plants
rather than animals if you had to guess
oh man uh so
this
isn't my guess now because we've talked
about this off mic before but before we
talked about it off mike
um
just kind of like based on
my assumptions about my own consumption
habits before i started tracking
i would have guessed that about maybe
three quarters of the protein in an
omnivorous diet comes from animal
sources so
so about a quarter from plant sources
yeah so when i started digging into this
research
my assumption was that the percentage
coming from animal based proteins was
much higher than it actually is
um
and i think a lot of that comes down to
demographics that inform those
assumptions so i'm going to put a table
on the screen here that talks about the
breakdown of animal versus plant-based
proteins in a diet now the world
worldwide average for an omnivorous diet
is 42 percent of protein from animal
sources and 58 from plant sources
that's a much higher contribution from
plant sources than i would have expected
but then when you start to break down
things based on
socioeconomic status
and you break things down into regional
uh localizations uh you start to see
that there are very clear patterns so
like for example in the americas um
we have we have a pretty you know
decently high percentage of our protein
coming from animal-based sources whereas
when you look at
africa and asia for example there are
lower percentages coming from
animal-based protein sources so part of
that is uh is regional it also breaks
down a little bit differently as you go
from lower income to higher income uh
categorizations but yeah the the the
take home there is that
in fact a decent percentage of protein
in an omnivorous diet across regions
does tend to come from plant-based
proteins and that's fine because when
you look at
even a small contribution from
animal-based proteins you are still
getting
plenty
more than enough of leucine and
essential amino acids lysine methionine
the whole deal so if you're on an
omnivorous diet that isn't like 90
plant-based uh you really don't have to
put a lot of effort into scoping out
these meticulously curated lists of
protein sources but that brings me to a
vegan diet
and i've mentioned on the show my diet
is getting closer and closer to vegan as
the years go on it's strictly vegetarian
but kind of flexible with with dairy and
egg but uh
a lot of people say well i'm a vegan so
i can't really lean on that assurance
that i have some animal-based protein
coming into the diet so what do i do
here right so sometimes vegans will who
are into lifting will think man this
sucks i'm gonna have to look into like
this huge list of like nine essential
amino acids for every single protein
source and really carefully kind of fit
this puzzle together and fortunately
that's not the case practically speaking
when you look at
plant-based protein sources we can
categorize them in a very convenient and
efficient way so a lot of the common uh
plant-based protein sources we'll see in
the diet uh can be categorized based on
the particular essential amino acid that
they are coming up short on so
i'm gonna put a graphic on the screen
that's from bodybuilding.com
i i understand that you know food
selection is regional so these
categories aren't going to be perfectly
representative of every region of the
world but this was looking at stuff that
you might find in like you know these
are all food sources i would expect to
see in an american supermarket walking
down the aisles
but there there's a group of proteins
that are missing threonine and lysine
and so we're talking about oats rice
rice
pasta rye wheat corn
there's a different group where you're
missing methionine so beans lentils
peanuts chickpeas peas and soybeans
there's also a category where you're
where you're specifically missing lysine
so that would be walnuts cashews sesame
seeds sunflower seeds uh pumpkin seeds a
bunch of seeds and nuts basically
so what's really convenient about this
is when you categorize protein sources
basically all you're trying to do to to
meet the um to meet your needs for amino
acids is just make sure that you're not
picking all your proteins from one of
these groups right you want to have what
they call complementary protein sources
which basically means uh if if all of
your so your protein sources that you're
currently going to
seem to be missing methionine so if
you're just like hanging out totally in
group b
just try to work in some protein from
group c right and so what you're trying
to do is mix and match these groups a
little bit and it doesn't have to be
perfectly done it doesn't mean you have
to have 50
50 of your protein from group b and 50
from group c or something like that what
it means is you just want to have a
mixture from multiple groups that are
making up your daily protein intake and
as long as you're doing that and you're
meeting basic general recommendations
for protein intake
everything else seems to sort itself out
just fine so those general
recommendations which are important
based on the literature
you want to make sure that you're
getting at least 1.6 grams of protein
per kilogram of total body weight per
day or
if you do a little bit of math
that generally breaks down in most cases
to aiming for at least two grams of
protein per kilogram of fat free mass
per day that's for if you're like
approximately trying to maximize muscle
growth right yes if you are trying you
can't go lower
absolutely yeah this is for optimizing
hypertrophy this is not for supporting
general health yeah yeah um
general health basically you you'd cut
these in half right yeah usually you go
0.8 grams per kilogram
um
is that how how it goes i think that's
yeah yeah we the fitness industry has so
uh aggressively [ __ ] on the rda for
protein that i've
basically forgotten what it is yeah but
yeah yeah i'm i'm pretty sure it's point
eight yeah it is it is um but yeah so
those those are the targets you want to
shoot for again if you're trying to
maximize hypertrophy you're lifting uh
you also want to split that protein
ideally if you can into like three to
six servings per day how important that
is is subject to debate a lot of what we
know about those specific protein uh
distributions a lot of it's based on you
know acute studies that lack ecological
validity some of it's based on studies
that don't involve a resistance training
component which like i said
provides a not just a large but also a
long lasting stimulus for protein
synthesis but if you're interested in
optimization
it shouldn't be too terribly difficult
to break your protein into
somewhere between three to six servings
per day if you say listen i gotta do it
all in one meal that's fine based on the
literature doesn't seem to be optimal
but you can still go a very very long
way with that strategy in terms of
hypertrophy and then again you just want
to make sure that there are no glaring
lacks of any particular essential amino
acid and all that requires is making
sure that you're not literally getting
all of your protein from a particular
group like we mentioned previously with
those complementary protein categories
you just want to make sure you've got
some pro some proteins that have plenty
of methionine some that have plenty of
lysine
generally speaking threonine is it's
important but you don't have to work as
hard to to make sure you've got it
covered usually you're going to have
enough to get the job done
so um i think that covers a huge
percentage of questions and concerns
related to protein intake and
again uh
you know
the general
uh general take-home point here is
it's probably not
uh beneficial to get too bogged down in
the details about micromanaging
really you know small differences in
specific protein sources what you're
trying to do is hit those general
recommendations have a nice mixture of
proteins in your diet you should be good
to go two caveats i want to mention like
you alluded to this entire segment was
basically assuming that you lift weights
and that you're interested in maximizing
hypertrophy so that that's an important
caveat or kind of clarification to add
on there
this is not like a
segment about general health guidance
another caveat there might be situations
where an individual is restricted to a
low protein diet for medical reasons
not my place to say what those reasons
should be if you're working with a
qualified health care professional and
they need you on a low protein diet
they'll let you know not me on youtube
um
but in that scenario if you're like okay
i'm i am restricted to a lower protein
diet
but i have an interest
for for a variety of reasons and getting
as much strength and lean mass as i can
that is a specific scenario where i do
think protein quality could become a
more pertinent issue because what you're
trying to do there is basically get more
bang for your buck and focus on
protein efficiency you know so what is
the smallest total grams of protein i
can ingest while getting maximal benefit
for supporting hypertrophy uh and
strength gains and
most almost certainly if you've got a
qualified health care professional
telling you to restrict protein you're
going to be well below the intake that
that meets those general recommendations
i gave for lifters so in that case
that very specific kind of unique
situation
i do believe it makes sense to then
prioritize higher quality proteins it
doesn't mean a protein score of 94 is
totally different than 91 but you will
probably want to prioritize just so that
you can try to get all your bases
covered with leucine and essential amino
acids without having to take in you know
1.6 grams per kilogram per day